hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on 400 and today we're
gonna be doing a little bit of a
challenge video and that is to basically
play as gladiator but without using his
own attack now I'm not the person that
came up with this type of challenge I'm
gonna have to give credit where credit's
due
go be uploaded a video yesterday of him
playing Berserker without using light
attacks basically meaning he can't faint
so that's why I got the challenge from
I'll leave his channel in the video of
him playing Berserker in the description
down below if you want to check that
challenge video out but for today from
my character we're gonna be doing very
similar stuff except no zone attack
arguably one of gladiators most used and
best move in the game we're gonna not do
with that for a couple tools or brawls
and stuff like that so I'm using the rep
60 character I made yesterday fully gold
and all the golden stuff looks really
supreme so we're gonna be using that
some duels and brawls and let's get in
to the video oh no god damn it my first
match we have is a Centurion alright
I got me an out of stamina god dude I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill myself and the first
matchup is against in our ameesha not
even a rep one but I think he's got like
40 50 reps overall so much if you try a
new character also I forgot to mention
in the beginning even though I can't
zone that also means I can't feint the
zone either cuz I know that's obviously
a thing but I can't feint it because
that would just still be considered
using the zone so looks like I can't do
my little lot of stamina punished or
whatever so hopefully hopefully be okay
I mean I don't really know I don't
normally rely on using the zone too much
so I mean it's not gonna be too much of
a bother I don't think to be afraid this
guy is just learning his character so I
am stopping him just slightly but I
think I could do without using the zone
maybe the guy starts turtling then we
might have an issue but I have a few
ideas for that as well also showing off
the I am war effect from the tester
metal mode I believe that was from
probably the best event we've ever had
love the gold with it it's like an
alternative sulfuric sparks if you don't
have it it's great
it's really hard right now not to zoom
this guy as much I've loved see right
now it's just cuz he's so open and he
won't throw any moves in me
oh good feint it's just all that one
coming I was getting greedy get a good
deflects my stuff shelf Stella emote
again god this is such a good it's so
good because if you patch it with the
the I am war and it's just everything
looks so good I am more with sulfuric
Sparks everything just looks great
honestly just it's a great emo I'm also
liking the new look probably not gonna
keep it just because he's a rep 60 or
just cuz it's got all the gold I might
use it and keep it that way but most
likely not gonna keep this product gonna
use my same character as always Oh miss
that horribly the I didn't I didn't
counter guard break that because I was
actually a busted I was really close to
zoning but I actually like pulled my
fingers away from my controller so that
scared me a bit didn't want to ruin the
challenge there we go I was a close
fight I almost lost that because of my
my quick instincts to use that so we're
going to Game two we'll see if we can
get into a duel next game
if not I'll probably try to queue up and
brawl because I feel like in Brawl it's
gonna be a lot more useful for me to use
the zone which is of course gonna make
this challenge a lot harder so we'll see
if we can Cuban a brawl
[ __ ] that thought that was a Perry damn
good stuff
Oh shadow after the guard break
don't [ __ ] them up see if you just
randomly throw a heavy and sometimes it
works man yeah
big Perry - for please Oh is she almost
caught me on that one I caught her
though
got her lacking a bit nice baiting him a
little bit the Big Bang complaint took a
fight sir
see this Kent say when he was playing
gladiator gave me the honor
give me that honor of not interrupting
my execution so I'm not gonna do the
same to him what didn't do that
[Music]
I caught him again a big catch
damn I'm almost had it I almost had the
know I'm dead
haha [ __ ] dude that's my issue I almost
had him on the deflect I was like maybe
two inches off
maybe I don't know a cup of measurement
I'm talking there with two inches I was
close the one issue and I say this so
much on my stream but I never take my
own word for it it's just like can't say
do his thing because if you get too
active if you as soon as you move during
that top-heavy
he just counteracts it so I have to I
have to make sure that I don't do
anything like I just basically let him
do it whatever he wants oh the hyper
armor bro that feels bad like that
except actually hit that peri and not be
[ __ ] stupid yeah Ken says gonna get
mix ups and he's gonna kill me but I'm
surprised he'd probably let me [ __ ]
probably let me go if his time with me
damn good fight man yeah absolutely
smoked
damn caught me on that one
[Music]
ah dude he got me bro I thought he was
gonna do the helm splitter see like I
never see anybody used nature's wrath so
zan nature's wrath is an opener like
that gets me every time
good fight though next duels against a
allah bringer mister sir Gate 21 rep
interesting haven't bought it well bring
her in a long time not sure what this
dude's playstyle is gonna be but we'll
see that's kind of the issue though
which sucks is I'm trying to be not use
the zone when using the zone is really
good against him of all especially of
all characters right now would be a
really good idea but I can just dodge
his bad I could dodge his shove pretty
well one of these times he is going to
he's not going to fall over the light on
that shove and he's just gonna guard
break me just to watch out for
without drillings overpowered so I'm
gonna just roll right through that whole
movie
we're just injuring with toast stabs for
now we'll take as long as we want with
this game
[Music]
Ragna Perry that's gonna hit me into the
wall
I'm impressed he carried me that far
holy [ __ ] I went really far I did not
expect to be that far
ah Dan there goes my help that simple
back dodged and it got rid of my buckler
man that doesn't have much range as much
as it seems
it really doesn't and that's the only
thing I do not like about that specific
move is the range on it
so I have to remember that he's most
likely gonna keep dodge you know back
dodging that
why is that so loud
dan there goes me
I could've been really bad if your guard
broke me because that was a back dodge
unless my stuff
that's all while bringing us to do is
just light attack me no get me
eventually Danny called me with the
heavy as well impressive
wasn't expecting that hopefully my I was
hoping my Dodge frames would go through
that
damn he caught me on that
I start deflecting more impairing I'm
giving this guy too much too much damage
because of it
all right sir the light
you're gonna slowly inch his health away
it's the best thing I can do there we go
the heavy feats are working out really
well have you fainted no lights are
working out tremendously well I still
can't use the zone because there's so
many times that I could be using this
right now and it's it's not working out
I keep if only I had a hand cam like if
you could see what my hand so we're
doing the amount of times I've actually
liked to take in my right hand off my
controller just so I don't press the
button is actually absurd it shows how
much I use the that movement it's kind
of disgusting it also kind of shows how
somewhat garbage Gladiator is without
his own tech I mean like he's still good
but like his zone really makes him one
of the bet like one of the better
characters so I feel like I definitely
his zone would impact him incredibly but
I feel like it's still needed as much as
I as much as a lot of people hate it I
totally agree it needs to be nerfed at
one point however they do it is could we
be up to them that would have hurt
really bad and it's still gonna hurt I
don't know how I don't know how to
[ __ ] I don't know how to act without
a zone attacker I know this is really
weird I don't do this stuff and this is
this is an awkward way of playing all
good stuff
that's gonna be GG on that round good
stuff that was really close fight I the
reason I ran away is cuz I also I ate
did not want to be near this area with
the amount of walls that there were
there because that would have totally
killed me and I just needed to like
regroup real quick because I was just in
a bad spot he had the range and it was
just like a good at like a good idea to
be in so I definitely was like you know
let's just regroup let's go back to the
middle and let's recuperate so that's
that's why I backed off that was barely
in range
damn maybe I left a skewer fly one time
although that probably impacts me very
negatively it's not easy that move is I
might not do that he is letting these
rip and I should I should be playing a
little bit more passive
dammit bro that would that have been
such a good time for that fucked-up hard
dude he's he gonna really I thought it's
gonna throw me out of an upset this game
is weird
I'm that damn broken I [ __ ] up on the
Perry [ __ ] up on the punish I don't
know how I didn't hit that point I don't
know how I didn't parry that out of
stamina top light and then I just got
back to playing my aggressive self
against the character who loves
counter-attacking so I fell right into
his trap you know a good fight on that I
can look good run just wish I had my
zone though but yeah guys that's gonna
be the end of the base I hope you guys
did enjoy it's a little bit difficult
I'll definitely admit playing without
his own attack there's so many
situations I could have been using that
and fainting into a toe stab or
something but it really makes you think
and use a lot of your moveset more and
this kind of just goes to show what
would happen if gladiator zone was
basically irrelevant now he's still a
good character I feel like without it
but it would impact him very hard so
hopefully like if they I hope in the
future they do nerf is don't attack
I can definitely admit that it is a very
shitty tool but they need to make it at
least good enough so that he can still
use it and it's not like a irrelevant
move so hopefully they patched that in
the future or something like that who
knows man maybe he'll never get a nerf
to his own but either way guys thank you
for arcs in the video hopefully you guys
did enjoy it looked a VP did subscribe
if you're new I cover the informational
side of for honor that being balance
changes patch no it's hero updates info
news all that stuff about the game and
as well showing off some gladiator
gameplay and stuff like that so guys you
do enjoy that consider subscribing and
that guy's my two most recent videos
will be on screen if you guys do want to
check that out with that guy so burger
yesterday thicket bots in the video and
peace out
[Music]